in the opening scene we are introduced
to a janitor named Poe who is
transporting a dead body into the morgue
the body belongs to a popular and
beautiful Spanish actress named Anna
Fritz who died in her bathroom under
mysterious circumstances another victim
of toilet Gremlins Poe carefully
arranges her lifeless figure alongside
other corpses and then unveils her face
to capture a photograph surprisingly he
sends the picture to one of his friends
named Ivan not long after Ivan
accompanied by his friend Javi makes
their way to the same hospital as the
three start chatting Ivan abruptly asks
if Poe has taken a glimpse of Anna's
unclothed body the janitor says
obviously and reveals that her body will
remain in the morgue until the following
day hearing this Ivan becomes desperate
to witness it himself so he manages to
convince Poe to grant them entry however
Javi thinks it is inappropriate and
dangerous he attempts to convince Ivan
to leave but the latter has made up his
mind already he even forces Javi to come
along with them in the next scene 3 take
the elevator to the basement and as they
walk through the hallway Poe tells them
to pretend that they are lost if someone
happens to see them when they finally
reach the morgue he pranks his
companions by swiftly pulling back a
sheet revealing the dead body of an
elderly lady get pranked nerds the
friends are startled by what they see
but Poe tells them to relax is this is
not Anna he then directs them to the
beautiful woman's corpse and finally
unveils her face however to his surprise
Ivan pulls the sheet further down and
fondles her chest saying that she
doesn't even look dead he then implores
Javi to do the same which he hesitantly
does there is a special place in hell
for these weirdos following this the
guys take a dose of Narcotics and get
high Ivan who has become infatuated with
Anna uncovers her complete body and
wonders if it is possible to violate a
corpse in response Poe says that saliva
must be used for lubrication God
when asked if he knows this from
previous experience Poe admits to having
violated the corpse of a 19 year old
girl okay sweet this further excites
Ivan and he decides to proceed with the
heinous act Paul also agrees with him
but Javi appears to be disgusted wants
to go home ASAP but Paul urges him to
stay in the other room until they are
done after this Ivan sleeps with the
corpse and fulfills his desire the next
one to go is Paul and he seems pretty
excited about it however when he is on
top of her she suddenly regains
Consciousness Anna has somehow come back
from the dead but she appears to be
paralyzed and gripped with fear when Poe
finally realizes what's going on he
screams in horror prompting his
companions to hastily enter the room the
first one to respond is heavy he takes
the initiative and approaches Anna
urging her to remain calm he also
provides her with a glass of water and a
piece of cloth sensing the gravity of
the situation Javi turns to Poe and
inquires about what they should do next
however both Poe and Ivan are horrified
as they know that what they did earlier
can land them in trouble as the three
are arguing they are startled by
someone's footsteps coming towards the
morgue hence they hurriedly turn off the
lights cover Anna's body and hide
themselves behind the other slab soon
after another janitor rolls in a
lifeless body Anna tries her best to
summon her voice and plead with the
janitor for assistance however she can
only manage weak and barely audible
sounds due to her weakened condition
after the janitor leaves Javi rushes
back to Anna's side and tries to calm
her down the men are then faced with two
choices they can either report Anna's
Revival and face violation charges or
they can murder her and cover up their
crimes Ivan asserts that since the world
believes Anna is Dead killing her and
hiding their crimes would be the better
option however Javi thinks otherwise he
wants to save her at any cost even if it
means risking their own lives he then
drags in his slab towards the door to
get her out only to discover that the
door is locked to make matters worse Poe
has left the keys at its side as the
tension in the room Rises Javi begins
screaming for help but I Evan once again
intervenes and Yanks him away the two
then get into a vicious altercation
which ends with Ivan hitting his friend
hard in the head shortly after I even
realizes what he has done and tries to
apologize to Javi unfortunately it is
too late as the latter is already
experiencing severe blood loss realizing
the urgency of the situation Ivan
decides to leave Javi in an isolated
room in the hospital where he can be
easily discovered moments later the
third janitor enters the room prompting
Poe to step outside and engage with him
meanwhile Ivan places his hand over
Anna's meth to suppress any sounds she
might make he stares at her menacingly
almost as if he has no remorse
whatsoever outside po pretends that they
were inadvertently locked in after they
forgot the keys the janitor believes his
story and requests to see Anna's
deceased body but post skillfully
manages to lead him away inside the
morgue Ivan is distraught that he has
assaulted his own friend he attempts to
keep Javi awake by putting pressure on
his wound but all his efforts are futile
soon the innocent man passes away
leaving both his friends in a State of
Shock and guilt realizing the gravity of
their actions Poe breaks down in tears
fearing a lifetime times spent Behind
Bars however Ivan's demeanor suddenly
changes and he gets another idea he
wants to dispose of javi's body as well
so that the authorities don't suspect
anything meanwhile Anna overhears their
conversation and becomes scared in a
soft voice she pleads for her release
promising to keep her mouth shut po
considers accepting her proposal but
Ivan intervenes and pulls him out of the
room he then urges Poe to remain focused
on their plan asserting that their next
steps will determine the course of their
lives Ivan also mentions the fact that
they will be held responsible equally if
they are caught he is sure that Anna
will tell everything to the authorities
if they let her live as the two continue
talking Anna manages to maneuver herself
off the slab she then searches through
javi's pocket and locates his phone at
the same time Ivan catches her in the
act and hastily grabs the phone from her
Anna informs him that she called her
father and informed him that she
regained Consciousness Ivan checks the
phone and upon discovering a dialed
number becomes convinced that they are
in trouble they nervously escort an
upstairs but on their way an unknown
number calls javi's phone Ivan answers
the call while Poe ensures Anna remains
silent to their relief Ivan learns that
the call was never fully connected she
only managed to ring her dad for a few
seconds after returning to the morgue
and I rate Ivan slap Santa for her
attempted cleverness in response she
accuses him of violating dead bodies and
even calls him a freak unfortunately
this turns out to be a bad decision as
Ivan becomes convinced that she will
report him to the authorities if left
alive so he goes outside to find some
equipment with the help of which he can
dissect her body after he leaves Anna
tries to convince Poe to let her free
promising that she will not report him
to the authorities she also warns him
that Ivan is a cold-hearted murderer who
will not hesitate to kill his own
friends the statement leaves Poe
thinking for a while but then he
disregards her and binds her up left
with no other options Anna fabricates
his story claiming that Ivan strangled
Javi in her presence while Poe is absent
from the morgroom she asserts that he
never intended to take his friend to the
hospital unfortunately Poe once again
ignores her and places tape over her
mouth that side Ivan becomes trapped
behind the containers as some nurses
gather there to smoke while Poe engages
himself with cleaning the adjacent room
Anna carefully removes the tape and
frees her legs from the restraints she
lowers herself to the floor and crawls
out of the morgroom managing to conceal
herself just in time before Ivan returns
shortly after the men eventually catch
wind of the escape and begin panicking
they then rush in different directions
in search of her Anna evades capture for
a while but as she steps into the
elevator Ivan catches her and pulls her
back into the morgue he then decides to
suffocate her with bunched up sheets
ensuring no visible marks are left on
her body PO is a bit skeptical about the
idea as at this point he has started
feeling sorry for the girl but
nonetheless when his evil friend insists
he too gets in on the ACT Ivan and Poe
then suffocate poor Anna until she stops
moving and seemingly dies afterward they
lift her back onto the slab and proceed
to place javi's body into the Container
in the next scene Poe cleans and drapes
Santa's body with a white sheet to make
sure all her recent wounds are covered
he then aligns her with the other
corpses making it look like no one has
even touched her following this as Poe
gathers his belongings and waits for
Ivan he suddenly hears Anna Anna
coughing it appears as if she has come
back to life once again but in response
Poe calmly approaches her and instructs
her to feign death this reveals that the
murder was staged Poe simply pretended
to strangle her he never applied any
pressure just then Ivan arrives at the
scene prompting Poe to quickly cover
Anna he then approaches her takes a
final glance and departs from the room
however just as they are about to enter
the elevator Ivan checks his wallet and
realizes that he left his card in the
morgue Poe tries to persuade him to
leave it behind assuring him that he'll
retrieve it the following day but Ivan
insists on getting his card
unfortunately as he enters the room he
sees Anna alive and well trying to put
on a hospital gown this infuriates Ivan
as he realizes that he has been
backstabbed he aggressively grabs Poe by
the throat accusing him of plotting to
shift all the blame onto him he also
mentions that at this point he doesn't
even care if they go to jail suddenly
Anna sneaks up on him from behind and
stabs Ivan twice in the neck causing him
to bleed out and die witnessing this
horrific act Poe breaks down in tears
and questions why she would commit such
an act when Ivan had already expressed
his intention to leave Anna doesn't say
a word she simply gazes at him for a
while then she repeatedly stabs Poe in
his abdomen killing him on the spot the
movie on Susanna is seen staring into
the distance tears streaming down her
face and blood splattered everywhere she
has gotten her revenge
and good for Anna you know this is a
happy ending if you if you really think
about it
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching